- Here are my tips for reducing stress
around taking important tests.
Tip one, build a habit of practice.
Building a habit of
practice is super valuable.
I know I'm guilty myself of
sometimes I get so caught up
with something, or I'm
stressed about something,
that I almost freeze.
But it really should be
the other way around.
I try to remind myself that, Sal,
if you put time in on a regular basis,
if I use things like Official SAT Practice
to take practice tests,
understand my strengths
and weaknesses, work on
where my weaknesses are,
and I do it on a regular basis,
that's my best chance
of actually improving.
And we have studies that show
there's a strong corelation
between students who are
able to put in even six hours
and growing 50% more than expected.
So I really encourage you
don't get too obsessed
with the outcome, but
think about what can I do
on a regular basis, not all at once,
not binge-practicing, but what can I do
on a regular basis, day in, day out,
and you'll be really impressed
how much the gains will accumulate.
Tip two, share your feelings.
One of the things that
it's taken me many years
to discover the wisdom of, and
I hope to share it with you,
is whatever is going on in your life
that you think is unique to you, it's not.
It's probably happening in the minds
of everyone else around
you, even those people
who look perfect on social media
and always seem to have their act together
and their hair perfectly
combed and great grades,
they're feeling the same
things, the same stresses,
the same insecurities in their mind.
They might even be feeling
far more than what you are.
And so do yourself a
favor and do them a favor
by being vulnerable and talking about it
and talking about how you can
actually support each other.
I gotta tell you, even when
I was a student like you,
and even today, as I try
to navigate my own life,
by being able to have a support network,
people who I can commiserate with,
it really helps lower the stress.
And that's just gonna make
you a healthier person.
But also, the more
relaxed you are entering
into these tests, the better
you're going to perform.
And tip three, keep a bigger perspective.
One thing that some of
us adults often forget
is how sometimes stressful the
stage of life you're in is.
Us adults, we say, oh, I gotta pay bills.
I gotta do this, I gotta pay the mortgage.
But I can guess what's
going on in your mind,
'cause I went through it myself.
You're saying, hey, I've
gotta do really good
on this test, because if
I do good on this test,
then I might be able to
have that opportunity.
If I do well with that opportunity,
then I'll get that opportunity.
And then my life will be perfect.
But if I don't do well,
well then that opportunity
might not happen.
And then that opportunity
might not happen,
and then what will I be?
Who will I be?
And what I'd like to tell you,
and I'm literally, I'm not making this up,
I have gotten rejected and
I failed at far more things
than you can imagine.
And even though in the moment,
I sometimes thought all was lost,
a week later, six months
later, a year later,
I realize that actually it
wasn't that big of a deal.
And in some ways it was a blessing,
'cause maybe that wasn't the thing for me.
And so when you go into test-prep mode,
yes, of course, you wanna
do as well as you can,
but that score isn't you.
It doesn't define you.
You are so much more than that one score.
You are so much more than
what school you get into.
And I'll tell you a secret.
And this is after being
out in the real world
for over 20 years.
I've actually haven't
seen a big correlation
between where someone
happened to go to school
and how successful they might be.
And I even did the
successful in air quotes
because what society calls successful,
money, fame, all of
that, I gotta tell you,
also does not correlate
with real happiness.
Real happiness is knowing who you are,
doing what you can, but not
getting obsessed with outcomes,
not coveting things, not
coveting, I must do this,
I must do that.
Because no matter how much money you make,
or how famous or accomplished you get,
if you have that mindset,
you'll never be happy.
But if you say, look, I'm
gonna be my best self.
I'm gonna do right by myself
and right by the world,
and things will play out as they see fit,
then you'll always be content.
And you'll actually be far
happier than most people
on this planet.
So those are my tips for reducing stress
as you approach these types of tests
and a little bit of
general life advice too.
I hope you take it to heart.
Take it with a grain of salt too,
but I believe that it
might be really valuable.